bit of a quite busy morning
um there's not many of us on today's
we're quite busy
right they are in crisis mode here
can i take your temperature my love
there's too much to do
and not enough hours in the day to do it
okay
love i'll be back in a sec the floor of
this care home
is now full of nhs patients
every time you get a discharge you'll
always get another patient coming after
so it's a quick turnaround at the moment
so you can
feel that pressure from the nhs oh yeah
bearing down on you definitely yes
yeah this care home
is trying its best to hold back the new
surge in this crippling pandemic one
week you know
i'd had a shift on the weekend i
couldn't it was completely fine
you know everything was going well the
next week i come back
every single name on the board had a
little sticker next to it saying they
had covered
and i literally was terrified it'll be
lunchtime soon so you want to be sat up
don't you for lunch
eva's a third year medical student
working part-time
as a carer here look at the board we're
absolutely full luckily no one's got
covered at the moment but
who knows what's going to happen in the
next few weeks
and that's the thing pressure on health
and social care is rising
demand for beds higher than it's ever
been
care homes like this one have never been
busier
and that's because more patients are
arriving here from hospitals that are
bursting
at the seams this is what the third wave
of this pandemic looks like
and if the nhs is overwhelmed then the
same
will happen here
nationally there's evidence that care
homes are struggling to staff places
like this
a survey by the national care forum
found that care homes were operating
at absence rates of up to 50 in some
cases
i think this is a experience that you're
seeing and the experience we're hearing
from members is a really
important early warning flag that we
must pay absolute attention to we want
to ensure
that those care homes are available and
those community services are available
for people
coming out of hospital but unless they
have the staffing to do that of course
they can't do that in the way that they
want to or in a way that any of us would
expect
[Applause]
it's just like what how would closers
ground dog do
you you just expect the same thing every
day
one person gets discharged another
another one
yeah day after day yeah i get asked
plenty of times because we do swabbing
as well for our staff
when's this going to end when's this
going to end
and you can't answer it
i'd love to see tomorrow or next week
[Music]
i well answer that one so we just keep
going
[Music]
they have fought this virus for months
now
and they're tired and worn out but in
the face of all of that
the care continues nick martin sky news
sheffield